Wonder Woman has arrived in theaters, and
much to the disappointment of comic-conscious
nerds, it went incredibly light on the Easter
Eggs.
Sure, we were treated to an island full of
Amazons that seemed pretty faithful to their
comic counterparts.
But the film didn't have a single inexplicable
time-traveling Flash cameo.
What's a wonder-nerd to do?
Let's roll up our sleeves and see what secret
DC references we were able to find between
the frames of Wonder Woman.
And of course, super spoilers ahead.
We all scream
Because it's a comic book movie, Wonder Woman
borrowed a huge chunk of its content from,
you know, comic books… just in a very general
sense.
However, eagle-eyed readers of DC Comics'
New 52 version of Justice League were quick
to spot a story beat cribbed directly from
the comic pages.
In the first few pages of Justice League #3,
Princess Diana has pretty much the same conversation
with an ice cream vendor as she does in the
film, though the comic presents a more modern
setting.
The story quickly diverges, however, as modern
Diana is quickly attacked by Parademons from
another planet, while movie Diana remains
hell-bent on hunting down Ares.
The scene gets another adaptation in the animated
feature Justice League: War, further cementing
the fact that despite having a pretty good
grasp on pleasure, Amazons don't have anything
on humans.
They have an isolated island paradise...but
we have Ben & Jerry's.
Point, mortals.
Four eyes
Wonder Woman doesn't have a very extensive
history on screen compared to some of her
contemporaries.
But her 1975 TV show is a thing of legend,
mostly because it was straight-up goofy fun.
What kind of Amazonian magic does it take
to spin around to change your clothes?
We never found out, but plenty of people got
dizzy trying.
Notably, 1975's Wonder Woman employed the
unrealistic trope that if you wear a pair
of glasses, you're completely unrecognizable
as the same human you are without your glasses.
So, when the cinematic Wonder Woman pops on
a pair of specs as part of her disguise to
blend in with lowly humans, it's quickly called
out by Etta Candy as being completely ridiculous.
Because honestly, it's about time someone
did.
Official business
Because Bruce Wayne is the richest man in
the world, he can afford to send armored cars
anywhere he wants, even if they just contain
a single photograph.
Meanwhile, the rest of the 99 percent just
has to settle for the post office losing their
birthday presents in the black hole that is
New Jersey.
Still, when Bruce sends around his Waynemobiles,
you'd think he'd be a little more subtle about
the fact that he's the guy assembling a group
of superhumans called the Justice League…
but no.
When you're Wayne levels of rich, you spring
for vanity plates, and you make sure those
plates have the initials of your secret super-team
on them.
Having the letters 'JL' lead off your armored
car's license plate is real subtle, Bruce.
What does your other car say?
"IMBATMAN"?
God Killer
So, as we learn by the end of the movie, it
turns out that the magical God Killer sword
can't actually kill gods.
And just like in the afterschool specials
of yore, the power to kick some godly butt
was inside Diana all along.
As far as DC Comics is concerned, the God
Killer sword is generally the domain of the
mercenary villain known as Deathstroke, the
Terminator.
The far-too-powerful weapon was crafted by
one god to kill another, and was given to
Earth's greatest assassin.
So while it's clear that Wonder Woman's big-screen
sword wasn't the real deal, there are rumblings
of Deathstroke appearing in the DCEU.
Could we get a look at the real God Killer
sword in the future?
Amazon prime
While it's not really an Easter Egg, DC went
all out in including Princess Diana's many,
many friends and relatives on Themyscira.
While some were named on-screen, a handful
are only mentioned in the credits.
Every single one of these Amazons has had
a few comic pages dedicated to them, even
if most of them are largely interchangeable
warrior women.
But maybe we'll see a couple of them again
in Wonder Woman II?
It's a miracle
There's not a whole lot of information about
that mystery gas General Ludendorff was snorting
in order to Hulk out.
But DC comics has a pretty weird history of
its heroes and villains taking strange substances
to perform superhuman tasks.
One early example of this appeared in 1940
under the name "miraclo," a "miracle vitamin"
that enabled the Golden Age hero Hourman to
do heroic things for sixty action-packed minutes.
While miraclo was developed for positive purposes,
it eventually fell into the wrong hands and
became a substance that Batman fans will be
very familiar with: venom.
Whether or not Dr. Poison's power-up gas will
eventually find its way into the bubbling
tubes of the supervillain Bane is anyone's
guess.
But the foundations have been laid to break
the Batfleck.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!